[Music]
there are a lot of reasons trump is
effective he's a celebrity he's
extremely entertaining he offered a
different set of policies than his
republican opponents in 2016. but one
other thing here
and i think it probably gives him an
edge over his prospective opponents in
2024
he's got a real relationship with people
people feel a real personal loyalty to
him they this guy is a billionaire from
new york who was born rich and got
richer and lived as a playboy and slept
with supermodels and flies around on a
gigantic airplane and yet he's so
relatable people feel like they have a
real relationship with him
and the same cannot be said
for pretty much any other republican in
my lifetime certainly not to the extent
that it's true of trump
and so that's why trump is leading in
2024 and make no mistake trump
as of today is running for president in
2024. people can bury their heads in the
sand they can say no no i prefer this
candidate or that candidate or this
other guy would be better yeah sure
maybe i don't know all i'm telling you
is as of today trump is running the man
just released
a campaign commercial
we are a nation in decline
we are a failing nation
we are a nation that is begging
venezuela and saudi arabia for oil
we are a nation that surrendered in
afghanistan
leaving behind dead soldiers american
citizens and 85 billion dollars worth of
the finest military equipment in the
world
we are a nation that allowed russia to
devastate a country ukraine killing
hundreds of thousands of people and it
will only get worse
we're a nation that has weaponized its
law enforcement against the opposing
political party like never before we've
never seen anything like this we're a
nation that no longer has a
free and fair press
fake news is about all you get
we are a nation where free speech is no
longer allowed
where crime is rampant like never before
where the economy has been collapsing
where more people died of covet in 2021
than in 2020
we are a nation that in many ways has
become a joke
but soon we will have greatness again
it was hard-working patriots like you
who built this country and it is
hard-working patriots like you who are
going to save our country
this ad goes on for i think three and a
half or four minutes and it's
it's all amazing i don't have time to
play the whole ad here but you i think
you get the flavor of it
that guy is running for president
and
i don't care if you are the most
hardcore
ron desantis ted cruz nikki haley
tim scott whoever is going to run for
president you might be the most hardcore
supporter of those people
you cannot deny that is a powerful
campaign ad
and so i'm not i'm not saying this to
say trump should run for president or
he's the best nominee or anything like
i'm just telling you it is a fact that
as of today he at least believes that he
is running
uh it's going to be very hard to stop
him even if the libs arrest him even if
they throw him in jail the man still
could run for president and so when
we're thinking about other candidates or
how to run the campaign or what 24 is
going to look like you've got to look at
it from that perspective right now far
and away in all the polls trump is the
leading candidate right now head on over
to expressvpn.com
michael knowles show big tech is more
powerful than most countries are they
profit by exploiting your personal data
it is time to put a layer of protection
between your online activity and big
tech that is why i use expressvpn think
about how much of your life is on the
internet
all of that information out there
every site you visit every video you
watch every message you send gets
tracked and data mined when you run
expressvpn on your device the software
hides your ip address something that big
tech can use to personally identify you
so expressvpn makes your activity much
much harder to trace and sell to
advertisers expressvpn also encrypts 100
of your internet data to keep you safe
from hackers and eavesdroppers on your
network what i like most about
expressvpn super easy to use even i can
use it you download the app to your
phone or computer you tap one button
boom you're done expressvpn does all of
this without slowing your connection
that's why it's the number one rated vpn
service by techradar the verge and
countless others stop handing over those
data to big tech
protect yourself with the vpn that i
trust to keep me safe online that's
expressvpn go to expressvpn.com michael
knowles show to get three extra months
for free
not to drive this point home too hard
but i i think it's really important for
the republicans now who are arguing over
2024
you have to grapple with the fact that
trump is the presumptive nominee
doesn't matter if they rate his home
doesn't matter if they indict him
doesn't matter if he's sitting in jail
you can run for president while you're
in jail it's already happened and the
guy who did it got a lot of the vote
eugene debs who was an actual socialist
the most prominent socialist in american
history that guy ran for president from
jail in 1920
and he got
6.8
or nearly 7 percent of the vote i think
so and you don't think trump would do
that
you don't think trump would run
wearing an orange jumpsuit from the
prison yard you know he would you
absolutely know he would
and so if the republicans want a
different nominee
that there's they're going to have to
undertake some kind of herculean effort
because right now especially after the
raid on mar-a-lago i don't see how you
beat that guy
unless
75 years of mcdonald's finally gets him
and i don't think so i don't think it
will i think he's he's very energetic
he's very very vibrant i don't see
unless he chooses not to run
i don't see how you stop him from
getting the nomination
i'm so glad you liked that clip now
you got to ring the bell you got to
subscribe we hit a million subscribers i
love that we got to go to a billion we
have to we have no other choice ring
that bell get the notifications we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]